ja letzte woche ich bin reporter film
alptransit afrika weiße farmer
ferienclub das hat viele reaktionen
ausgelöst
sehr viele likes auf youtube einige
kritische kommentare und dort zu einem
jetzt einstellig
ich liebe zu mich bemüht hier geht es um
gassis muss gegen weiße oder reparatur
auch ja und dann gibt es leute die
meinen rassismus gegen weiße gebe es
nicht
sie dämpfen gott vor allem darum das
vertriebs jordy nelson mandela auf
robben island and low wurden ist das
ereignis vor wald historische bedeutung
und er ein großer traum koffer der
rainbow nation wo im frieden mit sich
selber um mit der wald liegt und die den
schein ich sie morgen was ich aus dem
traum von nelson mandela wurden und das
haben wir frauen mit zwei aspekte handle
zweiten stock wo sich gestellt nach der
apartheid also was machen wir mit der
ungerechten verteilung ferland und
zunächst man die inhalte auf
freiwilligkeit gesetzt derzeit ein
williger käufer und ein williger
verkäufer werden sich finden und das
werde sich irgendwie regler mit und wird
stellt man fest das ist nicht der fall
ist immerhin 70 prozent von der
landwirtschaftlichen fläche wie sie in
der hand von der minderheit vor der
wiese minderheit und jetzt stellt sich
vorgenommen mit dem um und setzten
umschwung bei in süd auf dem kreuz
fordere mittlerweile teils ihre gierig
landreform und das könnte dann konkret
bedeute dass man wisse von island weg
nicht dass man sich an die enteignet und
das muss könnte und müsste dafür zahlen
also keine kompensation lustige und das
muss land eine schwarze würdige also
komplett die anderen zudem wo sich die
nelson mandela ford riskiere eine
vorgestellte das ist der erste punkt und
die zweite wo mich interessiert hat ist
kriminalität oder also wenn die racker
bogen aktion im frieden mit sich selber
und der welt dass wir stolz mit
kriminalität und dir hat enorm
zugenommen vor allem aber wie sie
verarbeitet fühlt sich der extrem
bedroht ein gefühl das richte sich vor
allem gegen sie wird durch richtiggehend
dezimiert
und da es interessierte stolp ist rar
und wenn du einen sitz mitwisser über
das gerät und dann aber haben mit dem
garten jugend muss sich wissenschaftlich
mit dem befasst wo forscht zu dem thema
und er sei krank zusammenhang mit der
fahrerseite kriminalität steigt
allgemein und betrifft auch und
besonders gesicherte mittelstandsfamilie
schwarze eu urbanen gebiet dass es
sicher so dass vor allem wie sie die
ländliche gebiet frauen betroffen
er wäre das sind also die große zwei
themen wo der film behandelt hat
woanders gibt hier bleibt hauptsächlich
ein nicht mehr zeitgemäßes schwarz weiß
bild hängen dass sich auch in den teils
ekelerregenden kommentaren widerspiegelt
wenn bei ihnen das bild des ekel
erregend schwarz-weiß-bild anbieter tut
mir das sehr leid absichtlich ein
anderes sieht absichtlich sieg zum
walburga warst riskio noch der
freilassung von nelson mandela aus dem
traum wurde nicht und ich finde das heim
raub konnte dass er differenziert ab
konnte
es gibt spannende grad vor dem griff zur
die ganze problematik stiegen die
kriminalität und wäre dass die vor allem
betrifft also ich finde man sehr
differenziert sich dadurch antworten wo
das sekret in schwarz weiß bilder
sprechen
genau dann schrieb die wichtigste frage
wurde hier nicht gestellt wie kommen
diese weißen farmer damals zu ihrem land
also die wiese schweizer pharma in dem
film die hand ihres land rechtmäßig
erworben jetzt was heißt rechtmäßig
seien zudem zieht wo sie oft hat noch im
garten der nacht noch im geltenden
gesetz kauft und die große und spannende
frage ist jetzt natürlich war es hat
noch verwehrt aber wenn der fonds könnte
apartheid aufgehört hatte nelson mandela
das geld wieder die blüten können ihres
land peilt den us centers for her
erworben
und jetzt stellt sich vor wie gut es
wieder geht es wenn andere im gesetz
bezieht plötzlich möglichkeit ihnen das
land wächst und dass man ihnen erleben
ist die zahle dafür das ist jetzt die
spannung frage antwort auf die frage ist
einfach sie als damals
noch galt in richtung gesetzeskraft es
gibt keine beweise dafür dass sie zu
zielen werden weil sie weiße form sind
na dann werden in gleichem maße auch
schwarze fahne ermordet hatte sich das
wetter das schwarze vorhang oder dumm
hätte damit schwarze fahrräder audi hand
anstatt ihr werdet befallen hat denen
wir zweigstelle wie diese formel wenn
der entsprechende drehtermine abgemacht
und problem schon ab der sich im märz 20
20 in südafrika bin und dann hatte ich
die ganze geschichte in südafrika
richtig angefangen hat eine müsse
frühzeitig die dreharbeiten abbrachen
und den lokalen mitarbeiter hatte ein
novitec viel mit versuchungen schon
abgemacht kann damit eine schwarze frau
hatten seine filme und die hand den
abnehmer welle die andrangs koffer
coruna übertragen und dann die termine
abgesagt aber es war blanik sie mit
schwarzer farbe aufnahmen zu machen
dann schüttet je costa nicht ganz
gelungen was wollt ihr mit der doku
überhaupt sagen irgendwie ziemlich
schräg und polarisierend war das absicht
der konnte der content wirkt etwas
strukturlos alles sehr verwirrend und
spielt irgendwie den rechtspopulisten
hier auf youtube in die hände
also muss ich ehrlich sagen ich kann
nicht ganz nachvollziehen wieso das dass
die rechtspopulistin die tanzspiele ich
glaube hand differenziert zwei fragen
gelockt wo es interessiert haben
verteilung vom land und wie ist das mit
der kriminalität und gruppe die
kriminalität aber mit dem geld den
jungen ausgewiesener experte
und ich finde das ganze sehr
differenziert ordnet das wichtigste ist
ich kann nach bestem wissen und gewissen
geschichte erzählen wo nicht das gefühl
haben sie ist richtig es stimmt ich bin
vergangener uni vorurteil auf die 130
millisekunden meinten oder in anderen
spielen und umgekippter andere nicht
sondern ich kandidatur classics innen
oder post berichteten
es ist wichtig eine solche reportage in
einen kommt
sechs zu setzen was mir hier fehlt
schritte david wenk ich aus gefühlen
hand für ihre reportage mit sehr sehr
viel archivaufnahme geschafft grad zum
teil selber gründen zum kontext schaffen
und ich das gefühl dass ich recht gut
gelungen
wenn es nicht viel mich wo primär aus
archiv besteht aber man kann durchaus
nein ich dir wichtig stellt erklärenden
element für die heutige situation zeigt
normal benannt normale geordnet und dann
ist natürlich froh was für frau geleitet
sitzt dort um sagt was ist riesengroß
das thema und sich zwangsläufig dass sie
30 minuten mit den fokus finden und
unser fokus ist sie was ist aus dem
traum von nelson mandela wurden verdaut
haben zwei sachen spezieller abrückt
erstens was ist mit der landverteilung
ist ihr achter wurde und die zweite
punkt ist die regenbogen nation hat
welle im fricktal aber mit sich selber
und wollte ich sie wirklich friedlicher
wurde und da stellen wir fest nein sie
ist nicht friedlicher wurde kriminalität
steigt und darunter leidet alle
südafrikaner eine weitere fragen oder
anregungen hand schrieb es keine
kommentare
wenn er gerne zudem ständig und dann
häufiger erstaunen die dokumentarfilme
und reportage interessiert dann
abonniere doch der kanal auch die vier
glocken will das gibt es spannende
geschichten und die ganze welt